[Musique]
la planète était l'objet d'une rencontre
entre les candidates du concours miss
earth et quelques collégiens et lycéens
de lille c'est bien de voir des jeunes
s'intéresser à la planète et devenir par
exemple avec nous des week-ends à les
nettoyer des plages
en tout cas les rencontrer d'autres plus
petit pouvoir véhiculer un message qui a
été un message fort je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes tous obligés
mais plus que de nous en tout cas d'être
concerné par cause environnementale
utiliser la beauté pour faire passer des
messages sans maître l'idée directrice
de ce concours
avec leur note les candidats se
préparent leur exposé sur la transition
énergétique car il ne faut pas oublier
l'essentiel
faut pas faire début le thème j'en ai vu
il ya aussi on est en compagnie de
l'association miss earth donc à brève ou
pas faire le thème sont devenus aussi
pour en tant que conseiller conseillers
départementaux jeunes donc certes y'a
les miss mais on va toujours
rester sérieux et enthousiasme oui le
viseur
je salue de défense on l'avait bien
compris et ronald zins des créations de
dieu pas certain non mais également les
générations futures
la présence des miss international donne
une autre dimension au moment pour ces
jeunes filles c'est la promesse d'une
belle aventure
ainsi elles y mettent tout leur coeur
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que je voulais de ma vie
les effets des actions concurrence
répétés sur le raid et la miss earth est
au dessus du gamin en fait on est vite
on ne vit pas une star pour sa beauté
pour son sens physique mais on les vit
surtout pour son angle son engagement
envers l'environnement
comme ce bloc
oui bien sûr qu'elle soit belle dans le
voyez témoin les candidats sont toutes
magnifiques la plantation d'un olivier
symbolique vient conclure ce moment la
recherche de sens est ici essentiel tout
à recevoir a du sens c'est un raid à
gauche ici en matière de notre avenir et
tout ce qui concerne
le développement durable un pensionnaire
j'ai tiré le réchauffement climatique
doit représenter du sens auprès de nos
élèves qu'ils soient à l'école primaire
au collège c'est à regarder les élèves
il semble que cette méthode de
communication fonctionne il faut sauver
la planète apprend qu'elle soit plus
catastrophique et d'abord des cycles est
respecté et essai de a pas moins de
déchets possible et qu'ils écoutent plus
parce qu'elles sont jolies
non pas spécialement mais
c'est ce qui m'intéresse encore ccc
l'environnement en fait c'est pas oui
oui elles sont jolies d'accord et ouais
ça ça me fait écouter plus gérer d'ici
trois semaines la représentante de la
réunion sera élu au jardin de l'état
et d'ici là la carte postale
réunionnaise permettra vient dé celle
fille
[Musique]